apparently people have been uploading
the play Hamilton on to pornhub like
they're trying to sneak it online that
way they're calling it hamiltoe I didn't
realize there is any market overlap
there okay like guys who like musicals
also like stepmoms getting peed on like
a weird Venn diagram of Shane okay I
just hope that's some meathead guy out
there like cracked open his laptop boner
and clicked on that link and then 20
minutes in was just like
[Music]
[Applause]
where are all the movies what is this
it's just 40 men wigs gotta know that I
did have a weird a porn related thing
happened to me this was like a year ago
one of my guy friends told me that my
celebrity look-alike is this porn star
named Jesse Rogers does anybody here
know that is figure out the liars in the
crowd if I ask in like Reno I get six
guys were like yo know we're home I okay
take it easy splash huh I didn't know
what she looked like so I google image
to her and like the first picture that
pops up is for with a dick at her house
the only reason I say this is because as
a comedian the thing you want so badly
someday is to get recognized in public
but I've completely forgotten about this
porn look-alike thing and I was in Los
Angeles a few weeks ago I was in a CVS
Pharmacy and a guy came up to me it was
like
I am a huge fan of yours
and I was like thank you so much
oh this is so cool
he goes i watch your videos all the time
I was like oh thanks yeah you know I'm
even trying only coat ones up right on
suck
[Music]
because who do you like working with
more guys or girls I was like oh I like
working with both one of my favorites is
probably Bob Saget his eyes got so big
and he was like Bob Saget's done
and I was like wait what because you're
just Rogers the porn star and I was like
oh no I'm Kelsey quick I'm a comedian
and he just goes away
and I just standing there like is being
a comedian grosser than being a porn
star I ain't felt so empty inside I
wanted to like fill that hole then I was
like oh this is how people go into porn